hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner  sorry and calm and today we're going to  demonstrate how to go up and down the  stairs while using crutches how does a  patient navigate up and down the stairs  while using crutches well you want to  keep these two straight and what I'm  meaning is which leg is going to go  first up the step versus which leg is  going to go down the step first and to  remember that remember good up and bad  down so whatever a patient is going up  the stairs their good leg is going to go  first up on the step followed by the  crutches and the bad leg which will  proceed and go up the step  now whenever they're going down the  steps they're going to move the crutches  down onto the stab that will help  provide stability followed by the bad  leg because a bad leg is going to go  down and then they're going to move the  good leg down on to the step  thank you so much for watching and don't  forget to subscribe to our channel for  more videos